hi developers welcome to serverless
migration station where we show you one
way you can modernize your code on one
of our serverless compute platforms i'm
wesley i'm joined by my friend martin
and our little friend porter to take you
on an alternate journey from app engine
to cloud run
good to be here again wes you showed us
how to containerize our app for cloud
run last time uh why are we doing it
again today well i'm glad you asked
martin in the module 4 video we did show
developers how to use docker to
containerize our app engine apps for
cloud run check it out if you missed it
containerizing your app engine after
cloud run is still on the to-do list
today but this time we'll do it without
needing to know about docker docker
files or how containers are put together
okay that sounds great but how are we
going to containerize an app without
docker yeah well we're going to use
google cloud build packs to do the job
instead of having to describe all the
steps for building the container build
packs lets you off the hook because it
does the heavy lifting it looks like
your code what language it's in its
third-party dependencies and so on then
builds the most efficient container
image you can check out these links and
this video from one of our colleagues to
learn more about cloud bill packs
that's good info uh but i'm curious uh
where did these build packs come from
yeah well they originated from heroku
back in 2011 and since then build packs
took off for different languages
different cloud vendors but in 2018 the
cloud native computing foundation
unified build packs under a common
standard google cloud build packs are
100 compatible with the cloud native
build packs and adheres to its open spec
check out the links to the cloud native
build packs and its spec
cloud build pass containerizes apps to
be deployed on google cloud whether
cloud run gke which is our managed
kubernetes service or compute engine vms
okay sounds good i can't wait to try it
so i did look ahead and i found out
there there's one module five finish
folder which is python three uh what
happened to python two wes uh
unfortunately build packs don't support
python two so if you do have a python
two up you gotta use docker but so our
starting point will be the python 3
version of the mulder2 cloud ndb app we
didn't containerize that one with docker
last time so let's pause right now so
all of you can go grab the code from the
module 2b folder or use our own from the
module 2 migration
got it you can also follow along in the
code lab and get hands-on experience
containerizing it with cloud build packs
let's start by confirming the module 2
code works whether using your app or
ours redeploy with gcloud app deploy and
verify you get the same output as from
previous modules if you've done any of
these migration modules you know that
this app typically doesn't change at all
that's the purpose right migrating
without breaking anything
just like in module 4 we're switching
products from app engine to cloud run so
make a full copy of your module 2 app
folder because like with docker you're
going to delete app.yaml as it's not
used in cloud run
next let's tackle requirements.txt
quick review app engine and cloud
functions are source based and start
your app with a production ready server
since cloud run is a little bit more diy
you have to roll your own
python app engine uses g unicorn if you
don't specify your own so we're going to
use that with cloud run by adding it to
requirements.txt
so it's identical to the one in module
2b folder except with g unicorn at the
top since i like to put mine in lowest
to highest level order
yes version numbers are a good practice
i left them out here because they change
all the time however they will be
updated in the repo
like with docker the app itself doesn't
change we're just containerizing it
right
the last thing needed is to launch a
gene unicorn to start our app with
docker there's either a command or entry
point directive at the end of the docker
file to kick off g unicorn with cloud
build packs there is no app.yaml nor
docker file instead we use a heroku
style proc file it's basically a config
file describing your app's processes and
how to start them
for our app there's only one process the
web server
it's basically the entry point directive
from app.yaml or the docker file so
create yours with this one line
specifying g unicorn as our web process
and boom that is it
we're also going to drop some links down
below so you can learn more about proc
files
and that we say is a wrap
run the same gcloud run deploy service
name dash dash dot command as you did
with docker or the longer version with
the platform type region and so on if
you're lazy like me and in about a
minute or less your app will be
available globally on cloud run
it should work the same as before
whether on app engine or cloud run with
docker
now you've containerized your app engine
app again but this time without a docker
file congratulations
wow i didn't know creating and deploying
a container would be that easy
buildbacks are amazing
since i don't have to worry about docker
files anymore i'm thinking about how to
increase my app's presence
while my users here in the us don't have
any issues my friends in sweden are
saying it's sometimes laggy
can i deploy my container to other
regions oh for sure martin in these past
few videos we use the magic one line
build and deploy command to get you
started with the least friction that's
gcloud run deploy with dash dash source
to specify the code to deploy for more
sophisticated usage let's talk about
breaking it up into two separate
commands that'll make it more flexible
to do the other things like what you
asked
sounds good wes uh i'm willing to give
up some convenience so i can more easily
deploy my app elsewhere
but you said the one line command builds
and deploys my container
can i guess that the two separate
commands are one for the build and the
other for the deploy precisely with the
one line command we got your app from
code all the way to cloud run without
discussing container images or other
resources like cloud build container
registry or its success or artifact
registry but since the cat's out of the
bag
here's the g cloud build submit dash
dash tag command you provide the full
image path which is made up of the
registry namespace like gcr.io or
package.dev respectively your project id
image name and possibly the region when
you build your image it has to be
registered before you can deploy the
cloud run registries help manage images
provide access control lets you check
for vulnerabilities and is where you
plug into ci cd integrations check out
the links to the gcloud build submit
command as well as both registries to
learn more okay so that's the build and
register step now how do i deploy the
same container image to multiple regions
hold on we're getting there martin
now that the image is in the registry
it's straightforward to deploy but
instead of gcloud run deploy dash dash
source it's gcloud run deploy dash image
where you provide the image path name
using this command you can deploy the
same image to other regions without
having to build identical containers
another benefit to having your image in
the registry is that you can launch
services directly from the cloud console
whenever you want from wherever you are
in other words you don't have to be on a
command line at your terminal you can be
in sweden to launch that service there
okay i feel good about containerizing my
app engine app for cloud run
what are some other app engine
migrations to consider
yeah well where you usually go usually
depends on the services you're using
apps using cloud ndb may consider
migrating to cloud datastore if you have
other code using that library if so take
a look at module 3. but if all you have
are apps using cloud ndb just stay where
you are if you're excited about the
firebase features in cloud firestore you
can consider that migration in modules 6
and 10.
if your app uses app engine task keys
consider migrating to cloud tasks you
can learn more about those in modules 7
8 and 9. finally if your app only has
one basic function or if you're
interested in breaking up a larger app
engine app into a set of microservices
check out module 11 to learn about
migrating to cloud functions whoa that's
a lot of options
thanks for pointing us to possible next
stops as well as these last two videos
showing users how to containerize their
app engine apps for cloud run yeah and
thank all of you for staying with us on
these short journeys in modernizing your
serverless apps this is wesley trent
from google cloud on behalf of martin
and porter and we look forward to seeing
you at the next migration station or on
another serverless expedition soon
[Music]
you